someone just won over 400 million
dollars in the powerball yeah you know
that lottery where you see all the
billboards and all the signs being
marketed usually by the government
trying to get you to go gamble somebody
just won over 400 million
now first the whole idea of the lottery
is pretty insane it's a way for them to
raise tax revenue and also just treat
people as idiots and try to get them to
go gamble on a lottery but ultimately in
a world that we live where we tell
people that the american dream is for
anyone in the world to show up here no
matter where you come from what language
you speak your education level your
wealth status who your parents are who
you know you can chase a life of
happiness and financial security in
america we also don't let anyone who
isn't rich invest in the private markets
well let them go gamble let them do all
kinds of other stupid stuff so the
lottery generally just doesn't make a
lot of sense to me but here's a person
who won over 400 million dollars but
here's the piece that i find the most
fascinating if you win 473 million
dollars in the jackpot well according to
sarah o'brien over at cnbc they've
calculated what the tax bill is it's
gonna blow your mind that tax bill ends
up being calculated this way most people
they don't actually take the lottery
winnings at the top level in terms of
amount they take the one-time cash
payment that would come out to about
283.3 million dollars in this case the
federal withholding tax 24
would reduce about 68 million dollars of
those winnings
then you get the top federal tax rate 37
you lose another 36.8 million dollars on
that one and then of course this person
based in arizona arizona state taxes
just under three percent and so they
would lose another 8.4 million dollars
and so when it all comes in of the 283
million dollars that they'd get in that
one-time cash payment from winning the
lottery they have to pay over 100
million dollars to the government in
taxes that sounds like a fantastic way
for the government to continue to get
tax revenue just have people keep
putting money into a pot and then just
tax the hell out of them once somebody
wins
one way to transfer
money from people who are dumb to people
who end up actually being really bad
allocators of capital i don't agree with
the lottery i tend to think that this is
just a way for them to literally take
money from citizens who aren't educated
enough to know that the odds of winning
aren't very high and it's a dumb
financial decision but if we're going to
allow anyone in our country to
participate in the lottery i think that
we should change the accreditation laws
we quite literally have written into law
that if you don't make more than 200 000
a year aka you're rich or you don't have
a net worth of over a million dollars
aka you're rich if you're not rich in
america you can't invest in private
technology companies you can't invest in
some of the best investment
opportunities available but you sure as
hell can go and buy lottery tickets
that'd make a lot of sense to me
can't choose both we're gonna let people
play the lottery let them invest in
technology companies we're gonna not let
people invest in technology companies
that don't let them buy lottery tickets
either but this is just one of those
things that shows maybe some of the
rules maybe some of the things that are
going on in society they aren't actually
structured in a way to help the everyday
person hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time